economics is the study of markets animal
sociology also involves the study of
markets many disciplines take an eye on
them it's important to remember that all
a market is is a group of like
transactions and all a transaction is as
a buyer and seller getting together a
buyer saying I want that a seller saying
I don't want it as much as you want it
because the price you're willing to give
me is higher than the price that I that
I you know that I that I need to keep it
and that's the nature of human Commerce
going all the way back to the earliest
days of human organizing an
understanding that all a market is an
aggregation of people selling and buying
similar things and that our models of
markets are just that they're models
supply and demand don't exist they're a
model of what we see in everyday life
that help us understand everyday life
when we add your great all those buyer
and seller transactions together and
helping students understand how human
society functions how it naturally self
organizes which is what a market is is
what a free market economy is because
even in the socialist economies and the
communists those markets existed they
may might maybe weren't tracked
officially but they were there and they
were operating and so when I think about
how we bring that into education it's
how do we help students understand how
humans organized how humans interact and
bring value to each other I love Adam
Smith calls it about our propensity to
truck now obviously I never thought of
that as a verb and had meaning back then
but I love that phrase now our
propensity to truck is what makes us
different from the animals our
propensity to engage in transactions of
me to sell you something and you to buy
it so that I don't you know you'll do
the farming and I'll do the sewing and
by having this propensity to truck will
each have more well-being in our lives
it's a very simple principle and I
sometimes think that when we use words
like markets and networks things we
create an abstraction of reality these
are models of how we exist
because I look at it the world and I see
what creates wealth and business by the
way for me is organizations and markets
which are both important parts of it and
it's organizations offering it aiding as
actors in markets and I look at it the
world and I watch it's not the
government that's creating jobs it's not
the governance that's creating
innovation it's not the church that's
doing it it's not you know you can get
something done so much faster with a
for-profit business then you can with a
not-for-profit or a government or a
religious based business or even an NGO
and you can move jobs and move wealth
and solve problems so much faster it's
pretty obvious it's the dominant social
institution now do I like that every day
no because sometimes as it's become the
dominant social institution we've
allowed market-based logics to dominate
our thinking part of how did 2008
occurred how did all your classmates get
lured as you talked about to Wall Street
is because money has become even more
motivating to us in the age of the
business of the dominant social
institution and money is only a metric
money is only one place of value in life
and if there's a sort of a challenge
that we're going to have if we're going
to react Willa Breit it's going to be as
a human on a psyche level understanding
how much business has come to dominate
and homogenize and control culture in
some cases and making conscious
decisions about where we're going to let
that happen and where we're not right
now we're dealing with the unintended
consequences of business emerging as the
dominant social institution and we're
beginning to have dialogues about how do
we push that monetary metric back a
little to let other values on the table
as a society both nationally and
globally
markets aren't fair or unfair markets
create wealth and they're incredibly
efficient at allocating goods and
resources and creating surplus for
society that makes people better off but
markets have nothing to do with how that
well-being gets allocated across members
of society and you can't argue they're
fair or unfair they're agnostic there a
moral not immoral a moral it's we as
human beings who get to decide how much
each person should be entitled to on a
moral and values-based level and I
personally am somebody who believes the
fact that a billion out of the six
billion of us on the planet live on what
less than a dollar a day isn't fair and
I don't believe that markets can solve
it I do believe they can create more
wealth to spread to help solve it but if
we just allow markets unchecked and
somehow argue that will take care of it
I've seen no data to indicate that
markets will know because they aren't
knowing they're allocating their
generative not loving